MALE SPEAKER: Today
with us-- Paul Vigna
and Michael Casey
with the book called
"The Age of Cryptocurrency."
So before we talk, I want
to tell you a little story.
Who of you were here when
Google announced a partnership
with Virgin Galactic, forming
a company Virgle, which
would go and colonize Mars?
Any hands?
No, you don't remember that.
Well, anyway, we did that
as an April fool's joke,
and the response was tremendous,
like hundred millions
of views in the first 24 hours.
And when people realized that
was just an April fool's joke,
we got a lot of mail
like, oh, man, why not?
It's time for doing it.
Like today's SpaceX is doing
something along those way.
So anyway, a couple of weeks
ago, I noticed on the internet
that Finance Minister of
Greece, Mr. Varoufakis
has announced that
Greece will actually
switch to Bitcoin, because of
all the financial troubles.
And boy, I was surprised.
And then I realized, like
after 15 minutes of research,
well, that was a well-played
April fool's joke.
And, of course, the
best April Fool's jokes
are the ones that are plausible.
So today with us, we have
Paul Vigna and Michael Casey,
who will get us into what is
this digital cryptocurrency,
and like what is
its possible effects
on the economic systems,
on the established order.
Let me just give a
brief introduction.
So Paul Vigna boasts
a collective 20 years
of journalism experience
as a market reporter
for the "Wall Street Journal."
Columnist and anchor for
"Money Beat," writer and editor
of the "Market Talk" column
in "Dow Jones Newswires."
Paul has been a guest of the
Fox business news network, CNN,
the BBC, and the John
Batchelor radio show.
He has been interviewed
by "Bitcoin Magazine"
and appears on the "Bitcoins
and Gravy" podcast.
Michael Casey writes
for the "Wall Street
Journal" covering global finance
in his "Horizons" column.
Casey has written
for such publications
as "Foreign Policy,"
the "Washington Post"
and the "Financial Times."
He's a frequent contributor to
the journal's "Money Beat" blog
and co-authors the daily
[INAUDIBLE] with Paul Vigna.
He's host of the book-themed
video series "Wall Street
Journal After Work"
and a frequent guest
and host of the [INAUDIBLE]
and "MoneyBeat."
He's the author of
two books-- "Che's
Afterlife, The
Legacy of an Image,"
and one of Michiko Kakutani's
best books of 2009.
And "The Unfair Trade, How
Our Broken Financial System
Destroys the Middle Class."
Today, however, we will
be talking about the book
"The Age of Cryptocurrency."
Please join me in
welcoming Michael and Paul.
[APPLAUSE]
PAUL VIGNA: I have
just become convinced
within the last
couple of minutes
actually that our being
asked to speak at Google
was not an April
Fool's Day joke.
I was not at all sure
until very recently.
So thanks for coming
out, everybody.
Glad you're here.
Glad everyone out in the
world there is also listening.
So this is going to
actually function almost
as two separate speeches.
I'm going to talk
for a little while,
and then Mike is
going to come up.
I'm going to hand
off to him, and he's
going to talk for
a little while.
And the two, they dovetail.
So hopefully, it will appear
like one seamless conversation.
But you're getting two for
the price of one here today.
So that said, first thing, I
want to start off-- I just want
a question.
And not that you
have to answer it.
It's a rhetorical question.
I'll answer it.
The question is, did
the financial crisis
matter to Bitcoin?
Did 2008 matter to what
happened to Bitcoin?
And there are really
different opinions about this.
On the one hand, you look at
it, and Bitcoin sort of exploded
right when the financial
crisis happened.
And on the other hand, there
are people that say no.
It didn't matter.
Bitcoin is a product.
It's an innovation.
It would have gone
out in the world
and done what it has
done regardless of that.
And some of the people
who hold that latter view
are extremely intelligent
people, some of the people
who are really involved in this.
And they have a very
strong opinion about it,
that Bitcoin is a
product, it is software.
It is something that is valuable
in and of its own right.
And it would have gone
out into the world
and made its way regardless
of when it was released.
But I can't help but
think that 2008 did matter
to what happened
to Bitcoin-- that
a decentralized, peer to peer
encrypted, anonymous currency
system that came out at the
depths of the financial crisis
struck a very strong chord
with a lot of people.
And that's the "Wall
Street Journal."
Mike and I write for them.
And you talk about
the period of 2008.
And you talk about really
the entire period of 2008,
when the crisis
started, through 2012,
through 2013, where you just
had the entire global financial
system lurching from
crisis to crisis,
just a cataclysm that threw
millions of people out
of work, that just waylaid
entire economies, from here
to Europe and Asia.
I mean, it really was a
massive just disaster.
Right?
I don't need to tell you guys
what kind of disaster it was.
We all lived through it.
And what I think that helped
do is, you have this crisis.
You have this--
not just a crisis
of economies, a crisis of
daily-- stock markets-- it's
a crisis of confidence.
You have this system
that we're all born into,
that we all grew up with.
The financial edifice that
we never had to question.
You never really
worried about it.
Suddenly, the thing seems
unbelievably fragile
and unbelievably shaky.
And let's not kid
ourselves, too.
It did crash.
It did collapse.
Governments had to
come in and bail out
the companies, the banks.
Governments had to come
in and prop up the system.
I mean, this was an
absolute collapse.
This was a problem.
And into that comes Bitcoin.
Nobody knows exactly
where it came from.
Nobody knows who
Satoshi Nakamodo is.
He releases it to this group of
cypherpunks on a mailing list.
It gets very little
attention at first.
And what I think is
interesting-- I'm
jumping around a
little bit there--
is that the cypher-- I
don't know how many of you
are familiar with
the cypherpunks.
But they were this group
of cryptography experts,
very concerned about
issues of privacy,
about issues-- all the
issues that revolve
around privacy and technology.
And they've been dealing with
this for decades, and decades
ago, had been thinking about
a digital currency, a coin.
This is one of
their prime ideas,
had worked on it
for a long time.
All of these
different precursors,
protocoins if you
want to, they'd
all failed for one
reason or another.
So that by the time Nakomodo
comes around in 2008
and releases Bitcoin,
they've kind of given up.
They've moved on.
They really did not give it
a lot of attention at first.
But through this
period that we're in,
2008, 2009, and the crisis, it
starts to gain some adherence.
It's very small.
But it starts to
gain some very, very
passionate, passionate
people around this idea.
And they are attached to it.
And you can see this.
What's really
interesting too is if you
go on the old-- not
the old, the current.
But if you go on the
Bitcoin message boards,
you can go back and look at
the entire history of them.
They're all there.
It's all online.
And in researching the
book, I had done this.
I had gone back
and looked at it.
And it's fascinating.
You can see it.
It goes from a couple of people,
to a couple dozen of people,
to a couple of hundred people,
to thousands of people.
And they are fueled by this idea
of a solution to this problem
that the real world
is going through.
All the time that we're seeing
these headlines, this solution
of an alternative currency that
completely sidesteps everything
that is giving us
all these problems.
And you start to see a community
grow up around Bitcoin.
And this photo, I'm very
proud of this photo.
Because if you look
in the reflection,
you can see that's me taking it.
So I kind of photobombed
my own selfie.
So that's my thing.
And what you see in the
years-- in these years,
this period of 2008
to 2012, really--
is a community of
extremely passionate people
coalesce around a currency,
which is a really odd thing.
I mean, to think of a
counterculture movement born
around a coin, even
a digital coin,
it doesn't usually happen.
But this community
grows, and it's techies.
It's libertarians.
It's people who are just kind
of fed up with the system.
And it becomes a
cultural movement.
It was really interesting.
And what you start to see is--
and I'm going to pull up here.
This is some artwork by
a California photographer
named Megan Miller, who did a
photography series on Bitcoin.
And this is what
you start to see.
You start to see not just folks
like you, technological folks.
Not just political folks.
But you start to see people who
start wearing the B, the badge,
as a symbol of something.
And Megan's artwork I
thought was very interesting.
And so I just wanted to pull
a little bit of it there.
I'm just going to go through
it quickly, if you want.
And this is what really
started fascinating me,
when I started
writing about in 2013,
was the cultural aspects of it.
Why?
Why do you have people
coming around this idea
of a digital currency?
And so you have you
Bitcoin artwork.
You have Bitcoin graphic novels.
Someone did a graphic novel
about the hunt for Satoshi,
which I thought was
really interesting.
And then this is a
really good artwork, too.
This is by another
California artist, Dave Kim,
who did-- I don't know
for you guys, that's
Dorian Nakomodo,
who in March 2014,
Newsweek said he was
Satoshi Nakamodo.
And Dave Kim was
not into Bitcoin,
but he was friends with
artists who were putting
on a Bitcoin-related art show.
And they asked
him to do a piece.
And he did that piece.
And I'm a little
proud of the fact,
too, that I helped him name it.
He had a couple different names.
He didn't know what to call it.
One of them was "Free Lunch."
And I said, well, it's
got to be "Free Lunch."
So I interviewed him, and
he said, yeah, of course.
Why not?
So I convinced him.
So you have photography.
You have artwork.
You have comics.
This is another piece of artwork
by [INAUDIBLE], a German artist
who did his 200 bitcoins.
And actually, I
took a piece of it.
I should have brought
the whole thing.
Because it's literally a field.
It's like a Andy
Warhol type thing.
It's 200 bitcoins.
It's the symbol.
Why the symbol?
I still haven't
completely figured it out.
I think some day
someone's going to do
a really fascinating
anthropological study
about this.
You had people who did music.
You had Bitcoin songs.
And I didn't bring
the songs along.
But you had a
Bluegrass Bitcoin song.
You had a Bitcoin love song.
You had a Bitcoin rap.
Nobody writes
songs about Paypal.
Why are they writing
songs about Bitcoin?
That's a Bitcoin ATM.
It's actually a
little out of place.
I don't know why I put
it in the slideshow.
I shouldn't have put
Let's go back to that.
That's interesting.
And this is what
I think is really
critical, is the idea of a
culture, a idea of a community
coming around this thing.
Because when you think of
what a currency really is,
we imbue currencies
with a lot of power.
We put a lot of mythology
into what the dollar is.
And who controls it actually
has a very powerful tool
in that mythology.
But ultimately, a currency
is really just an accounting
system.
It's a way for a group of people
to keep track of what they
have, who owes who to what,
and to make that a very
streamlined, simple process.
What you have now, I think, with
Bitcoin, for the first time,
is you have a way to
do that digitally.
You a way to do that online.
You a way to connect
people who are now
being connected
through social media,
but who previously
could not be connected.
Who couldn't interact
with each other.
Could interact with each other
on a very limited basis, right?
You could talk to each other on
email, or Twitter, or whatever.
Now they can do commerce
with each other.
They can send each other
things, and they can pay for it.
It becomes part of a whole.
It becomes part
of this evolution
of this online
digital community.
And I think that, if you
didn't have the crisis,
I don't know that that would
have really-- the crisis was
really like fuel for Bitcoin.
And it really kind of put a
groundswell underneath it.
And the whole thing grew
in a very organic way,
very viral way.
There's no marketing team
that's pushing Bitcoin.
There's no advertising
campaign for Bitcoin.
The whole thing was
extremely organic,
and it was all formed
around the community.
And in a very real, real sense,
the community became Bitcoin.
It wasn't just a
piece of software.
It wasn't just a protocol.
It is literally the community
that decides this thing
matters to us, and we are going
to use it among ourselves.
And that's what you end up with.
And I think that's a
very powerful thing.
Now, what the media still
sees is something like this.
Here is Ben Lawsky's
hearing in January of 2013.
Or 2014?
2014.
It's a random--
actually, I should
have taken this slide out, too.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PAUL VIGNA: What?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PAUL VIGNA: Anyway,
you still have
this sort of public
face of Bitcoin, which
is Mount Gox, which
is Silk Road, which
is regulators trying to
get their hands around it
and hold hearings.
And that becomes what
most people think
of when they think of Bitcoin.
But it isn't that.
It really is the community.
And these slides I
wanted to bring in,
because they're very visual.
But it's really interesting.
The guy, the large gentleman
with the frizzy hair
and the beard, his
name is Hooroo Jackson.
And he had invested in Bitcoin
early, and got rich on Bitcoin,
and used it to make a movie.
The movie is called
"Aimy in a Cage."
He was an aspiring director, and
he was able to fund it himself
through Bitcoin.
He hasn't released it yet.
He completed it.
And I just wanted to
pull up some slides.
Because again, it's
just an example
of how people were using this
for more than just a currency,
a token.
This became something that
became a cultural art,
being part of their lives.
And hopefully, Hooroo's
movie gets out there.
I don't know what he's
going to do with it yet,
but I just think it's
very-- it's not actually
about Bitcoin.
This is Austin and
Becky Craig, who
in 2013 wanted to travel around
the world using only Bitcoin
to prove that it could be done.
And they did it.
They drove across
country from Utah,
their home in Provo, Utah.
They came to New York.
I met them at a
Brooklyn pizza place.
That's where they are.
That was supposed
to take Bitcoin.
It was the only place in
the city that took Bitcoin.
So because they were
only spending Bitcoin,
they went to this
Brooklyn pizza place
to buy their pizza with Bitcoin.
And then they got on a plane.
They flew to Europe.
They flew to Asia.
And they managed to do it.
They managed to go around the
world spending only Bitcoin.
Did involve some homeless
nights, some foodless nights.
It was not easy.
But they did it.
And they showed in doing
it that, again, this
was a community that was
growing up around this thing.
And it was really taking flight.
No pun intended, actually.
It really was growing.
So this is what happened
all through 2008,
2009, '10, '11, '12, '13,
this community kind of grows.
And in 2013, it really kind of
explodes into the mainstream.
And now journalists are
getting interested in it.
The media's taking notice of it.
You still have all
the salacious stuff.
the salacious stories.
But suddenly, this thing
seems to come out of nowhere.
And people are saying,
oh my god, Bitcoin
is going to take over the world.
It didn't really
come out of nowhere.
And it really wasn't going
to take over the world.
And I think that was
a problem for it.
Because it appeared
that, overnight, this
was going to be a new
way of doing things.
And that was part of
what fueled the rise up
to $1,000, the speculation.
Everyone goes crazy over it.
And it put far, far too
much on what is still
something that is being built.
I mean, it's really
important to keep in mind
that Bitcoin is still
in a beta phase.
They are still
building the protocol.
They're still
building the system.
And I think that that
actually kind of came
to be a problem for
Bitcoin, because it
couldn't fulfil those dreams.
It couldn't fulfill everything
that people were putting on it,
and it starts to
have some problems.
And you can see there, that's
just in the first quarter.
And then the rest
of these slides,
actually, I should give
credit where credit is due.
I cribbed these off
of CoinDesk which
is a Bitcoin news service.
They do a quarterly
"State of Bitcoin" report.
It's actually very, very good.
2013, Bitcoin hits
its all time high.
Falls all through 2014.
The price comes down,
because this speculation
starts to seep out of it.
It's not going to take
over the world overnight.
It is not going to become
this thing that challenges
the homogeny of the US dollar.
It was not going to happen.
People start to get a little
disillusioned with Bitcoin.
They start to get a
little bored with Bitcoin.
But what was happening
is a different group
of people was starting to
come into the Bitcoin world.
And to call them, use a loose
term, call them the suits.
Money was starting to
get ahold of this idea
that there was
something valuable here.
The techies, the libertarians,
had built something.
They had put their
passion into it.
They had given a lot to it.
And they built this thing, and
they showed that it had value.
Even when you have a situation
like, say, that the Silk Road,
which is an online drug bazaar.
It is clearly illegal.
But as a use case for Bitcoin,
it showed that this coin works.
People could trade online.
They could buy and sell online,
and they could send the money
to each other directly online.
That's a powerful thing.
Then you start seeing
the suits get involved.
And about $380
million of VC money
went into Bitcoin in 2014.
These are two of
the big deals that
happened this past quarter--
Coinbase and 21 is a company.
They got about $200 million
between the two of them.
And people start
talking about, they
start comparing Bitcoin
to the internet.
This is another kind
of valuable chart.
It shows where
Bitcoin was in 2014,
in terms of VC
investment, compared
to the internet in 1995.
And you can see
that there's money.
There's real money
coming into Bitcoin.
People who care about
making a profit,
who care about
building things that
are going to be good for
them in the long term,
are starting to get
interested in it.
So that has become--
and I think, actually,
in 2015 that's a huge story,
the idea that Wall Street is
getting interested in Bitcoin
as a technology, as a product.
As you see sort of the
cultural part of it fade away,
you're starting to see this
business case be made for it.
But Bitcoin is kind of
reaching a crossroads.
The really passionate
people that
were going to come on board
early-- the early adopters,
the techies, the
libertarians, the artists
that really were looking
for something new--
that community has kind
of saturated itself.
Bitcoin has saturated
that community.
Can you find people outside of
that that are interested enough
to get on board?
That's another
question right now.
And it's a problem.
This is the number of
Bitcoin accepting businesses
added in each quarter.
And you can see the
number of businesses
are-- the growth rate
of the businesses
is starting to level off.
Because businesses,
they take it.
They accept it.
They say, oh yeah, this
is kind of interesting.
At the last, we can use
it as a marketing thing
to attract this crowd.
But they're not
finding that there's
a lot of business
being done with it.
So you're having fewer
and fewer businesses--
even though you have big names.
Microsoft is using it
in a limited sense.
Dell is using it
Big companies are understanding
there's something there.
They want to experiment with it.
But they're not seeing a
huge groundswell of business
from it.
So that's another issue.
And this is another slide.
Actually, these
next few slides, I
think I'm going to leave
them up for Mike when
he starts talking.
Because this kind of
really gets to what
you're interested in Mike.
What is Bitcoin
going to be about?
What is Bitcoin for?
Is it really for
first-world US citizens
who have access to all kinds
of banking services, who
have access to any kind
of credit they need,
using another one?
Or is it really about people
who live in emerging markets.
People who don't have
access to banking services.
People who can't really
build up the kind of wealth
that we take for granted.
That, I think, is where
Bitcoin-- that is really
what I find very
fascinating about Bitcoin.
That's what I think is Bitcoin's
biggest, to use the phrase, use
case.
I think that is where
Bitcoin is going
to really prove its worth.
And I will say,
too, me personally,
when I got involved in
journalism, I did it-- well,
when I got in journalism, I
did it because I needed a job.
And my only salable asset
was writing and editing.
It was the only thing
I could do well,
so I got a job in journalism.
But the reason I
stayed with it was
because I wanted to be able
to tell stories that I thought
were important.
I wanted to be able
to tell stories
that I thought mattered
in terms of improving
the human condition.
And in 2013, I
realized that I think
Bitcoin can help improve
the human condition,
and that it is
part of that story.
And I was one of
those people that
became very, very-- that
groundswell came under my feet,
and I became very
obsessed with Bitcoin,
and I got very into it.
And Michael also, and that's why
we wanted to write this book,
because we think there
is a very, very big story
to tell here, and we
wanted to be a part of it
in any kind of way.
For me, writing stories is
my way of being a part of it.
I'm not a VC.
I'm not an entrepreneur.
I'm not going to go
into those businesses.
I'm not going to start
up own Bitcoin app.
I want to tell a story.
I think Bitcoin's a
very-- I think it's
a critically important story.
But I think it is
also a story that
is it at the very, very early--
I keep saying very, very.
It's at very early stages.
This thing is only
six years old.
Like I said, it
is still in beta.
It is not even in version 1.0.
They are still
building this thing.
Over the next 5,
10, 15, 20 years,
you are going to see this go
in places that we can't even
think of right now.
The way I look at it is I
think it's as if this is 1896,
and we're all living in
our little rural community
with dirt rows that
your horses go down.
And you just saw the first
horseless carriage go by.
And it scared the hell
out of your horse.
It might have scared your wife.
It scared you.
And you don't know what it is.
And it's very odd,
and it's very unusual.
And your initial reaction
is, that thing has to go.
That thing is dangerous.
That thing is going
to hurt somebody.
We've got to get
rid of that thing.
There's a quote by--
and I'm jumping around
in my historical
references here--
there's a quote by
a second century
Italian writer named Tertullian,
who had said the first reaction
to truth is always hatred.
And I think that's a really
kind of interesting way
to think about new ideas.
The visceral reaction to a
new idea, usually, is hatred.
It's doubt.
It's skepticism.
It's nah, this can't work.
And I'm that way, too.
When I first heard of
Bitcoin, I was the same way.
I said, I'm not writing
about this thing.
This is a scam.
This is a con.
It's a Ponzi scheme.
It's not going to last.
I actually did, I said I
refused to write about it.
But I kept thinking about it.
And I kept reading about it, and
it kept popping up in places.
And then I started
getting interested.
And then I started reading more,
and I started writing more.
And the more I read, the
more I saw there was to read.
And the more I wrote, the
more I saw there was to write,
until the story just got
bigger and bigger and bigger.
And I think it is
going to keep getting
bigger and bigger and bigger.
And where it goes from
here is not exactly clear.
And that's where I'm
going to hand off
to Mike, because Mike is
going to talk about some
of those things.
And I don't think
I went over time.
I hope I didn't.
But I'm going to hand off
to my esteemed colleague
and co-author, Mike Casey.
MICHAEL CASEY: Thank you, sir.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL CASEY: So you've
left me some extra slides
to work my way through.
PAUL VIGNA: I thought
you could play with them.
MICHAEL CASEY: But
that's a nice slide.
You didn't get to talk about it.
But anyway, OK.
PAUL VIGNA: Actually,
I should have.
Because I was talking
about the unbanked, right?
MICHAEL CASEY: That's all right.
Yeah, and the unbanked,
and property titling,
and a lot of really interesting
use cases for Bitcoin I think
are going to be very, very
important down the road.
But I'm going to talk about
something a little different.
And it is to talk about this
concept of the crossroads
that we're at.
The transition from a
very passionate community
of true believers, driven by
sort of maybe some libertarian
ideas, and some
very strong views
about kind of a utopian vision
for the world, newcomers.
Those newcomers are
not necessarily--
they're a very
different community,
and they have a
corporate flavor.
And that's a very
important issue
for how we deal with the
structure, the infrastructure,
of not just Bitcoin, but
cryptocurrencies generally.
And you guys I think need
to think about this stuff.
Anyway, I was
pleased to see, when
I came in through the
airport last night,
that there was an ad for this
right there in the airport.
Some of you actually
may be familiar with it.
This is an ad for
Charles Schwab's
new intelligent
investing algorithm.
And for awhile,
in Grand Central,
they were running ads without
the name Charles Schwab,
just saying, you know,
investing will change forever.
And leading you to believe that
in March something really big
was going to happen.
But when I saw it,
I couldn't help
thinking how much it
reminded me of this.
And you know, it's
kind of interesting
that this comparison
would be made.
But if you look at
them side by side, HAL
and [? Shrub's ?] intelligent
algorithmic investing machine
had the same spooky
light in the distance.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MICHAEL CASEY: Yeah, exactly.
This is the thing.
Well, that's weird
now, Boris, is
what they've done is they're
now running ads on TV
with a spooky British
voice behind it.
How they would do
it, I don't know.
But it's interesting.
So Dave, I'm afraid I can't
help you with your portfolio.
You know?
I'm an Aussie, by the way.
So I'm not going to get
that accent quite right.
But anyway, this matter is, I
think-- this is a judgement.
I certainly don't mean
to pick on Schwab here.
Because the idea that you
have a centralized algorithm--
and this is the point.
The idea that this
is not actually
your intelligent investors
that are [INAUDIBLE].
Of course, the algorithm
is owned by Schwab.
It's not your algorithm.
It flies in the face of the
Bitcoin ethos, if you like.
That the algorithm really
cannot belong to anybody.
It needs to belong
to the community,
and it needs to
be something that
doesn't allow the centralization
of the information,
and therefore the idea that
some powerful corporate interest
could just morph into HAL.
And I'm not here to pick on
Schwab about this, of course.
Because algorithms are
essentially owned by companies
all over the world, and
I'd be remiss to point out
that I'm speaking at the
offices of the company
that owns the most powerful
algorithm in the world.
So there's nothing wrong
with this principle.
It's just that it
speaks, I think,
to what drives the dream of the
Bitcoin world, the idea that we
can shift this out in
a decentralized way.
And it matters right
now because, as Bitcoin
goes through this
crossroads process,
there's all sorts of
other interested parties
who-- really noting how
important it could be.
We were talking
over lunch actually
about how the-- there's a
struggle that those of us who
think Bitcoin's an important
issue face with the way
the mainstream perceives it.
As much as there is this
incredibly passionate community
that grew very quickly.
It seems as if they've
reached a roadblock.
Because once you step outside
of the realm of the techies
and the libertarians,
the utopians,
the fringe dwellers if you like.
Not to cast aspersions
on all of you tech types,
but there is something--
you are not middle America.
Middle America has
a problem with it,
because they perceive and see
all sorts of other problems
with it.
What's happening, interestingly,
is that these guys
are getting involved.
They're getting involved, and
mainstream is going, what?
The New York Stock Exchange?
What are they dabbling
in Bitcoin for?
Why would you ever want to
get involved in something
that's being run by criminals?
And yet, it's happening
over and over again.
So you can see
the New York Stock
Exchange invested in Coinbase.
Duncan Niederauer who
just coincidentally
was the previous CEO of NYSE,
he joined a Bitcoin swap side,
TeraExchange.
This one's really
interesting-- Blythe Masters.
some People see her as
sort of a sinister figure,
but she really is a genius.
She created credit
default swaps, really.
And she's now left
JPM, JP Morgan,
and is the CEO of Digital
Asset Holdings, which
is an interesting
new settlement--
digital currency and digital
asset settlement service.
NASDAQ not investing,
but they're certainly
providing the tech
for [INAUDIBLE] market
to build a new Bitcoin exchange.
UBS just announced a
new block chain lab.
And Jamie Dimon, who spoke
disparagingly about Bitcoin
about a year ago,
now says there is
much for us-- that is JP
Morgan-- to learn from Bitcoin.
So this is a sign.
These guys are now
getting interested.
And it's important, in the
context of this centralization
versus decentralization debate.
Because they're all
profit-seeking companies,
quite rightfully so.
I mean, as Peter Thiel
reminded us recently,
you need the search
for monopoly.
You need the search for
profit to drive innovation.
The challenge-- and
I'll get to this later--
is how do you prevent
that monopolizing process
from becoming something that
kills innovation, that stifles
growth, and that ultimately
turns the rent seeking
activities that are inherent
to monopolies into something
really quite destructive.
And this is the thing I want
to come to in a little moment.
But what's happening as
this corporate mainstream
interest is growing?
We saw Paul lined out
all the VC money that's
coming into Bitcoin.
This is another part of it.
You know?
The Wall Street and other
interests, what all of them
are saying is this.
I like the blockchain,
but I don't like Bitcoin.
And this is something that gets
people in the Bitcoin community
kind of upset.
It need not, I think.
But there's an enormous
amount of passion caught up
in what that represents to
people in this community.
What they're talking about, and
why people get upset about it,
is that they say, look,
it's impossible to have
a blockchain without a coin.
This idea that you
had no digital value,
because you need this coin
to secure the blockchain.
If you have all these miners,
all these participants
confirming transactions,
why on earth
are they going to
participate in this network
if you can't reward
them in some way?
So the idea is that the
coin, that token of value,
is critical for the building
of value, the incentive
system that builds
the consensus model,
and ultimately, therefore, the
security of the ledger itself.
It's not clear that
they're necessarily right.
Now, they are right on
the fundamental question
of decentralization.
But if you just switch
this around a little bit,
and we just think
that, well, what about
if we had a centralized
Block chain?
Or better put, what if we had
a permissioned blockchain,
whereby the nodes, the
computing-- those that
are providing compute resources
to the process of processing
transactions were actually
given some sort of authority
to do so?
That there was some entity
that said, you know what?
You guys are going to
participate in this,
and here are the reasons why.
And there's a vested
interest in participating.
And for that reason,
we don't need the coin.
Because we've got an
authority to do so,
and we have a reason
to do so, which
is kind of the legal imperative,
the mandate, the charter,
whatever you want to
call it, to do so.
So we're already actually, to
some extent, in this world.
Where we have
permissionless blockchains,
Bitcoin being the best
known-- some of the alt coins
like Litecoin.
And Ethereum, the
remarkably expansive idea
of a new versatile blockchain
that Vitalik Buterin,
the wunderkind developer
came up with, all of which
depend on the idea that anybody
can come in and participate
as a miner.
And then you get
permissioned Blockchains.
Ripple is probably the
best known of these.
I'm sure you've probably
heard of Ripple.
Where there are gateways
that participate.
And they're ultimately
given this role.
And then there's this
newcomers on the block,
Aris Industries out of
London, and Hyperledger.
And they're building
blockchains that
could be used in corporate
settings, where the focus is
on the power of the ledger
and the smart contracts that
work within them, rather than
necessarily on coins and value.
But when the
bitcoiners come back
and say, look, this isn't going
to work, you just can't do it,
it still evolves into
this question about why
these companies care about it.
And at the end of
the day, there needs
to be a kind of commercial
use for blockchains.
So companies are
worried about Bitcoin,
because it has these
sort of broader concerns
that the general public
is worried about.
It is, at the moment, too
volatile as a functioning
currency.
There is this problem
of criminality.
And there is the insecurity
that digital wallets have.
And some of these
really are, in my mind,
not particularly big issues.
Because I do feel as if
innovation, even regulation,
and just general
network effects,
will eventually
resolve some of these.
Probably of greater
concern-- these
concerns that I think more
sophisticated analysis bring
forth and that are focused
on the protocol itself.
It has scalability limits,
particularly in terms of data.
The fact that it takes
10 minutes to finish
a block-- this is a Bitcoin.
Other alt coins are
much faster than this.
It takes an hour to have
a final confirmation.
And then of course, you've got
this problem of the mining arms
race, where the incentive
system has actually
built this massive race toward
massive amounts of computing
power.
And the concentration that's
been built around the mining
pools on that basis leads
people to some concern
that we could have a bad actor
one day taking 51% control.
It hasn't happened until
now, and there are probably
good game theory reasons as
to why that wouldn't happen.
Who wants to destroy
their own value?
But nonetheless, it's
a legitimate concern
that hangs over
Bitcoin all the time.
And a lawyer from
a large company
is probably going to feel
uncomfortable with that very
risk always being there.
And then there's this sort
of problem of consensus.
Bitcoin's achievement
really was the capacity
to incentivize-- to marry the
incentives of the individual
to the interests of
the group, and to make
sure these things
worked together.
It resolved, in some
respects, the tragedy
of the commons problem,
where we're all
pursuing our self-interest
in destroying
the public good that we have.
But at the same time, the
model as it's structured
limits the capacity to
sort of build out further.
And so that same problem
starts to reemerge.
In that, what really
would be probably better
for Bitcoin is to
allow the capacity
to innovate, to allow to
build this system out and grow
on a-- in a more expansive
and innovative way.
But if you have to keep getting
the consensus of everybody
to do that, and nobody
wants to do so because it's
against their own
personal interests,
you once again are back to the
tragedy of the commons issue.
It's kind of like the UN.
It's impossible to get the
UN to do anything sometimes
because you just need consensus,
and it's very hard to develop.
But these problems
are being resolved.
I mean, there really is
some remarkable amount
of innovation going on, whether
it's Vitalik Buterin's project
or it's what the guys at
Blockstream are doing,
to try to build a side chain
that would allow innovation
to happen in isolation
but connected to Bitcoin.
There's a lot of work
going on in this space.
But at the same time,
the corporate sector
really doesn't care.
They just want something that's
practical and commercially
viable for them.
And so they're focusing on
what they say they do like.
They want to do
away with this coin
that they think is just
too much of a distraction.
And really, who cares about
whether the Fed goes away,
and why do we need a
community currency anyway?
Why can't we just deal with
some of the other cool things
that this blockchain can do?
And so they're
talking about some
of these great ideas about
fully orderable databases,
and how you could more
appropriately manage them.
The idea of smart
contracts that might
remove lawyers, and
escrow, and managers,
and trustees from the
capacity of two entities
to trade with each other.
They like the idea of
peer-to-peer real-time payments
and settlements to make
the ACH system-- well,
to ultimately do away
with ACH and to improve
the transfer of value
around the world
and free up all this capital
that's tied up in that.
Provable asset
registries, we talked--
there's a brief reference
to it under [INAUDIBLE]
in that earlier
presentation that Paul gave.
And he's got this
idea that we could
bring property title for
the poor of the world
and place it onto a
blockchain, this idea
that perhaps we could liberate
capital as a result of that.
And then we could
turn securities
into digitized products
and trade them.
And so, there's a lot
of focus on these.
This is what they like
about blockchains.
The advantages?
None of this insane race
to-- concentrated mining
and the arms race we
were talking about.
It's a safe network,
because there's
no threat of a 51% attack
when a central company would
manage the blockchain itself.
It would be scalable.
If this was a
centralized model, you
could just set it to the
parameters that you wanted.
Fast.
And this UN problem goes away.
You don't need the consensus
of all of the participants
to get things done.
But ultimately, there's not much
in the way of disadvantages.
But they're critical.
The very fact of
centralization, and the return
to the idea of trust, are
potentially dangerous.
Now, it doesn't mean that
there isn't potentially
an enormous amount of
value to be unleashed
by moving to a centralized
blockchain that would do away
with the problem of
the coins, particularly
in a corporate setting.
There's a bit of a debate about
why on earth you would do this.
What benefit could you bring
to a company, when in fact you
could just run a smart
database instead?
Why do you need to build
this elaborate chain
of interacting nodes
within your company
to fulfill these functions?
And there's actually been some
interesting work done on this.
Tim Swanson, who is
in the audience here
today has put out a really
interesting paper recently.
People are focused on the idea
that there's a smart contract.
That's really what Bitcoin is.
And so you could
imagine-- and I think
the jury is very much
still out whether this
is going to function
this way or not--
but a company could
perhaps set up
a structure in which
different siloed units,
different divisions within the
company that have for so long
had to depend upon these rules
and processes, the requirement
that XYZ manager has to sign
off on this RFQ and this guy
has to do that.
Anybody who has worked at a big
company, and all of you have,
had kind of a management
and procurement or any level
that deals with the
movement of funds
and-- it can be incredibly
laborious, cumbersome,
and bureaucratic.
And the idea that you
could now use a blockchain
to automate a lot of
those approval processes
and maybe find interoperability
between differently
arranged software stacks, and
different parts of the world,
you could perhaps develop
efficiencies around that.
Would it outweigh the cost of
building that system rather
than, again, a more
sophisticated central database?
I don't know.
But I think the
point to make here
is that, from a company
perspective, who cares?
Like if you can
actually prove that,
and a company can make life
more effective for them
and save money, go for it.
That's a way to bring value, and
every company should and would
pursue anything that's going to
save money internally for them.
The concern, to get back
to this problem about why
centralization and
trust matter, is
not for that kind of a
centralized blockchain,
but what's being
sort of described
as the federated
Blockchain-- the idea
that an association of
entities with a shared
interest in something
ends up working together
to supplant the role that
the miners currently play.
In a permissionless
environment, you'd
have permissioned members.
Now, the example I have
there is the TBTF alliance.
Too Big To Fail, of course,
is the reference there.
And I wanted to
throw out the idea
that, as those banks that are
getting interested in Bitcoin
and Blockchain right
now explore what
seems to be one of
the things they're
most interested in, which
is a more efficient process
through which money and
securities are settled
around the world, removing
middleman-- making
that process far quicker than it
currently is, so that you move
from three days,
to one week, down
to virtually real-time, freeing
up massive amounts of capital
in the process.
Trillions of dollars a
day are traded in world
foreign exchange markets.
If we could get that money
to flow instantaneously,
the impact on the globe
could be profound.
There could be great savings
for the global economy.
The problem is
that, if that were
done in a model that is
controlled by the SIFIs,
the Systematically Important
Financial Institutions,
as the bureaucrats
are now trying
to deal with the mess that was
the 2008 crisis describe them,
what are we doing?
You know?
We're once again
centralizing information
around the power of
these institutions.
And what 2008 told
us was that it's not
just that centralization
inherently breeds monopolies
and therefore
rent-seeking activities,
and ultimately denies
people the chance
to obtain products
at a fair price.
But it also, when
pushed to the extreme,
and certainly when backed
by the political support
that the implicit backstop
that we taxpayers gave to banks
does, it can be really
destructive to society.
We centralize
information and control
around institutions that
have controlled the system,
and it can do an enormous
amount of damage.
And here's the point.
Whereby if I think about Google
as a centralized institution,
and its own clear
profit-seeking motives
is different from a bank, is
because the infrastructure
in which a bank is
operating-- the banks own it.
It is already a centralized,
controlled platform.
Right?
TCP/IP, for whatever it's
worth, is an open system.
It is there.
And that is the thing
that makes Google continue
to be an innovative company.
And regardless of
whatever the EU ends up
saying about you guys, there is
a profound amount of innovation
that happens here,
precisely because you never
know when the next competitor,
disruptive competitor,
is going to be coming
over the horizon.
And that is possible
because the infrastructure
is available to all
to exploit, to create
disruptive,
innovative new ideas.
As we move into the age
of the internet of money,
where we're trying to move
value into this same powerful,
seamless, programmable world
that the rest of the world
has already moved into.
The real risk here is that
we deny that same capacity
to the banking system,
and that we end up
with a recentralized
model around
the actual infrastructure.
We don't care about
what the app makers can
do-- what the banks and
their profit seeking entities
can do there.
What matters is
the infrastructure.
What matters is the platform.
So the concern is that, as we go
around this debate, blockchain
without Bitcoin,
the idea that we
can have some sort of
coinless structure here,
I think it's absolutely
critical that we--
those of us who are
invested in this,
but I mean that as a society.
Because this truly
is an idea that
is far bigger than the
kind of hobbyist notion
that people in the general
mainstream still think
Bitcoin is.
There are really profoundly
important issues at stake.
So those of us that
are invested in
that-- be they writers, techies,
or people in the finance world,
it's beholden upon
us to try to fight
for the guarantee of some sort
of decentralized, open sourced
basis to this transformation.
And companies could,
and should, and will
do what they need to do.
And blockchains that are able
to operate in efficient ways
internally may well
be a fabulous solution
for that process.
But I just think that
the passion actually
needs to be sustained around
this decentralization issue.
And if, at this moment of
crossroads, where we're
going from-- the fringe
dwellers have handed the baton
to corporate
America-- we lose out
on the capacity to fight for
the importance of this platform
being a decentralized
infrastructure.
We face some very big risks.
We don't want to go back to 2008
or some other version of that,
and we certainly haven't
fixed that problem.
So it seems like
an arcane debate.
And I wrote a column
on this yesterday
the sparked a lot of interest.
And people get very upset
about whether or not
blockchain can be
without a coin or not.
And the problem is that
it gets lost in a world
that the rest of us
don't seem to understand.
But it's critical.
So I'm just going to
leave you with that.
And there's the cover
of the book, which
is actually on sale afterwards.
We have to do the pitch.
But we're happy
to take questions.
Do you want to come up
and stand here with me?
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: We're going to use
the microphone for questions,
please.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for the talk.
It was pretty good.
What are your thoughts on
the centralization of mining
that's currently going on?
I know a lot of the
fringe dwellers,
including me, were
able to participate
in that part of the
decentralized system.
But since about a year,
I think that's pretty
much over for everybody.
So it's just a large-- couple
of large data center companies
that own most of
the mining hardware.
How do you think that
that will affect Bitcoin
as a decentralized platform?
MICHAEL CASEY: I think it's
the most important issue.
I mean, it's-- and again, this
is part of-- the debate gets
focused on, oh,
Bitcoin's too volatile.
And it's criminals.
That's the issue.
Because that talks to the
core problem of the consensus
infrastructure and
how it builds out.
Now, is it a problem
that we have this?
It's certainly a problem
for a little guy who
wants to make some money in it.
To me, the issue is
around whether or not
there is a 51% attack concern.
Really, that's ultimately it.
I'd love to think that we would
be in a more democratic world,
and everybody could
participate in it.
And that is also an ideal that
I think is worth pursuing.
But I think a greater
concern is that it
is exposed to insecurity if
it's just a case of just owning
all the hardware.
So I think the pools need
to be resolved as an issue,
seriously.
Now there may be ways to
do peer-to-peer pooling
or something that
moves that aside.
But the other issue
is, have a sort
of pragmatic view
about the importance
of working with
regulators and making sure
that government has a view as to
how Bitcoin is going to evolve.
And to the extent to which
that mining activity is now
concentrated in China,
for example, a lot of it
is these data pools
that are based
behind state-owned enterprises.
Where the Beijing government
doesn't know they're there,
but some party
[INAUDIBLE] is paid off,
or is being paid off, rather,
by the Bitcoin miner who's
using the free electricity
that's subsidized by the state
to run this thing.
That's hardly the kind of
comfortable infrastructure
that the US government's
going to look to as
the foundation for this system.
So [INAUDIBLE] that's being done
by companies here in the US--
Bitfury is one of
them-- to try to build
a bridge to regulators,
to be much more
transparent about their
activities, how much control
they have over mining, where
their data centers are based
and so forth.
That's probably the most
important issue right now.
I don't know how easily
we can wind back the clock
and allow you to
participate at this stage.
But certainly, making
sure that the threat
of a 51% attack and that the
security is under control,
that's just paramount
as far as I'm concerned.
AUDIENCE: Michael,
could you do me a favor?
For the audience on
YouTube who don't know what
a 51% attack is, could
you go into details
of what it actually means.
MICHAEL CASEY: Absolutely.
OK.
Sure.
Yes.
I forget with the
YouTube audience
we've got a different
audience from this one.
So a 51% attack is the
notion that-- the blockchain
is a verifiable record of all
of the transactions taking place
in Bitcoin so long as we
can assume that nobody has
the power to manipulate
transactions and actually
have the system approve
fraudulent transactions,
transactions that were double
spent, is the classic problem
that people [INAUDIBLE].
Kind of a form of digital
counterfeiting, if you like.
And the reason why it would
be possible with a 51% attack
is because, if you
owned more than 50%
of all of the computing power
that is distributed to manage
and confirm the transactions
in the blockchain, then
by virtue of the way that
the algorithm creates
the blockchain chain, you'd be
able to consistently enough win
the awards for preparing
a block and would
be able to build blocks
of your own interest.
And that block would
become the longest chain.
Bitcoin is built around the
idea that the longer the chain
of transactions,
the longer of blocks
in the transactions, that is
the de facto legitimate block
chain.
And that is basically
the burden of proof,
that all the data
behind it is true.
So if you had 51%,
you'd actually
be able to more consistently
build the next block.
And you'd have
the longest chain.
You could ultimately
destroy the system,
because you could
put whatever you
want into those
transactions, and the system
would regard that as the truth.
So that's the sort of
complicated problem
that a 51% attack is.
And it's something
that's really been
of great concern and a lot
of debate for some time.
AUDIENCE: I've got a question
for both Michael and for Paul.
For Michael, real quick, if
you do trust the transparency,
if you have to identify
yourself as a validator
underneath the scheme that
Bitfury is working on,
doesn't that defeat
the whole purpose
of having pseudo-anonymous
validators,
if you have to dox yourself
to be part of the network?
MICHAEL CASEY: You
know, I don't know.
If you assume that that's an
inherent part of the thing--
now I don't know.
Maybe there's different
degrees of documentation.
Maybe there's certain aspects.
You don't know
exactly where it is.
To be honest, I don't
know technically
enough to understand how
far you would push that.
But certainly, the idea of
some transparency behind it--
MALE SPEAKER: Wasn't the
whole network designed so you
don't have to be transparent?
Like it's the assumption
that every actor
is supposed to be
pseud-anonymous
and has its own incentives to
do a certain type of action?
MICHAEL CASEY: Right.
But maybe there's
some degree to which
there's enough
information out there
about who's involved, who's
acting, how much you control,
that is at least going to
bring some sort of security
that network.
Even if where your nodes
are and who you are
is not actually
sort of necessarily
identified as who you are.
I mean, I don't know
exactly if it is.
But I think it's hard to
deny that, for the sake
of confidence and
trust in the system,
I think this is one of the
things that often comes--
AUDIENCE: But isn't it
supposed to be trustless?
I mean, why should
you have trust?
MICHAEL CASEY: The
trustless and trust thing
I find-- to me, trustlessness is
this sort of holy grail concept
that bitcoiners have
obviously held up
as an important principle.
But at the same time,
it's never going
to get anywhere unless there's
trust in the system itself
from people who use it, and
therefore from the government.
Trust and confidence is
the essence of money.
So building some degree of
transparency, and openness,
and accountability,
around those who
are working in
this system I think
is an important compromise,
a bridging thing
between those two concepts.
Where you overstep the line and
suddenly destroy all the value,
because all of a sudden,
you've lost the pseudonymity
and so forth, I don't know.
But it is-- it's
important to recognize
that there's a challenge in it.
PAUL VIGNA: And I think to
real true believers in Bitcoin,
this is a core issue, right?
The whole issue of identity,
pseudonymity, anonymity.
But to most people, I don't
think they really care.
Most people don't care.
Most people
broadcast their lives
on social media and they--
I think this idea of privacy
has been so eroded.
I think most people just
really don't care about it.
They want a product that works.
I think it's an important issue.
I'm not saying it's not.
But I'm saying that I could
see somebody like BitFury
or somebody else come along and
build a system that does not
put anonymity as its Godhead
and still build a product
that people would use.
It's just a matter of what
you think philosophically.
AUDIENCE: I have one
question for you then, Paul,
since I already picked
on Michael a little bit.
So you mentioned Bitcoin's
in its early stages.
Maybe it's early stages for
investors who just picked up
on it, or journalists, or people
interested on the outside.
But from like a network
security standpoint,
it's already given
up 2/3 of its mining
rewards over the past six years.
It's basically a senior citizen.
Like we're depending on fees
at this point to sustain it.
It doesn't seem
empirically to-- anyone
wants to actually pay for fees.
So in the long
run, how would you
say it could stay
as middle aged,
or become young again, from its
senior citizen status in terms
of network awards?
PAUL VIGNA: Well, again,
I think that's an issue,
especially if you
have invested hundreds
of thousands or millions of
dollars in infrastructure
to be the person, to be
the miner, to be the node.
The price matters a lot.
The fees matter a lot.
Right?
It kind of gets back to
what you were saying.
Idealistically, this would
not be good for Bitcoin.
But I would love to see the
price go down to like $30
and see what happens there,
see the shake out there.
And then you would
have a situation
where it would be cheap
enough that you probably
could do it on your own again.
And the entire
system resets itself,
and you have a very
different makeup
of people comprising
the system than what
you're talking about now.
That could happen.
And personally, I
think Bitcoin's price,
if it does survive
as a product, if it
does survive as a
protocol, I think the price
is going to come down.
Because I think as
its utility gets
proven out, its usefulness
on a day to day basis,
it becomes less-- it
becomes demystified.
It becomes less speculative.
It becomes just this thing
that exists that you use.
Nobody's going to want to pay
$200 for it or $1,000 for it.
They might think it's worth $30.
They might think it's worth $1.
It becomes much more useful,
and much less valuable.
Kind of like you wouldn't
pay $1,000 for a hammer,
but you'd pay $12.50 for
a good hammer from Sears.
And that's
idealistically speaking.
That would be a big problem
for the people who have bought
into the system right now.
But I could see that happening.
And you have a shakeout,
and it's a problem.
But other people will
come in, and the system
will reset itself and move on.
So you know, it could go
through some senior moments,
you might want to say.
But I don't think
that necessarily
has to be a death nail for it.
MICHAEL CASEY: On the
question of fees replacing
Bitcoin rewards, and
this notion that we've
gone to a point where that's
just no longer viable, yes,
it's obviously a challenge.
And I suppose the question
becomes, like anywhere else,
where's the value proposition?
I mean, if ultimately the
fees have to rise to a level
that they exceed-- we end up
with transaction processing
fees that are something
like credit card and Visa,
than what's the point, right?
So there's a concern, and
it's a legitimate one.
And I know there's a
big debate about, well,
if we start putting all
this extra value on top
of the blockchain and
trading large property
securities and so
forth, who would
want to do that if there's not
enough background security?
To Paul's point, they
actually probably want
the value to rise higher
so that you have--
to the opposite of
that, so that you've
got enough of a security basis
for big transactions to happen.
The question that becomes how
economical does that become,
and what miners-- it's kind
of like to me, you know,
we don't know.
Right?
I mean, there's just this
huge, big experiment.
What is going to be
demanded, and what's
going to become--
what are miners going
to need in return for processing
the amount of information
that's going to passing
across this blockchain?
And I just-- it's
an article of faith,
but I think there is a sense
that these problems can
be resolved.
I mean, we've gotten this far.
I don't know how.
You can have a much
better grip on how
this thing would actually
be physically designed.
But I just feel as if we've
proved-- it's lasted this long.
It actually has--
to your point, maybe
it has become the senior
citizen in that sense.
The good side of that,
it's actually survived.
It hasn't been destroyed.
It has actually
functioned to this point.
And there's a lot of innovation
and money and interest
in making this thing work.
And on that basis,
I feel as if there's
going to be ways to innovate.
It might not be the economy.
It really is going to
be a problem, perhaps.
The 21 million
might be the limit.
The compensation
system just might not
be sufficient to sustain this.
But at the same time, we've
got the workings of a model.
We have the
blockchain as an idea.
And my point is
simply that whatever
shape it takes, whether it's
a Ethereum or something else,
decentralization still
needs to be an objective.
It needs to be a very
important objective of how
we take this thing forward.
AUDIENCE: But my
understanding of the pool
is still a bunch of
different people, right?
Who all-- they essentially don't
want to gamble with the, oh,
might I find a
bitcoin ever or not.
Right?
They just want
some small portion
of each bitcoin that's found,
proportional to how much
they invest.
Right?
So how is this a danger?
MICHAEL CASEY: Well,
it's a danger because
of the way that the server--
PAUL VIGNA: We're talking about
two different things, right?
I mean, you're talking
about the big pools.
You're talking about
basically the contracts,
the hashing contracts.
Right?
You're like, you buy a
contract, and somebody
has a small [INAUDIBLE], and
you get a little piece of it.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: No, I'm
talking about mining.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MICHAEL CASEY:
--contract, or you
could be your own
separate miner.
Either way, you still
belong to a pool, right?
So the pool is the way
to efficiently distribute
a piece of what's happening
rather than having
to rely on the idea
that just once you
might win the next
block three years hence.
Right?
So it's a way to
actually portion it out
on a more steady
flow what that is.
And that would be-- it
wouldn't be a problem at all
if the pool
structure had nothing
to do with voting power and
the application of the capacity
to determine what the
shape of the blockchain is.
But it's not like that.
It is that the pool
itself, it has the capacity
to actually set the next block.
The pool becomes the
administrator of the block.
It's drawing upon the hashing
power of all of its members
to then becomes the next block.
All right?
So that gives it enormous
administrative power.
I mean, that's why it
comes up all the time
when GHash.IO, which was
one of the biggest pools,
got over 51%.
There was a some great concern
that they would use that power
to launch the attack.
Now, they didn't, because not
in their interest to do so.
That's the other
point of this, right?
Is why would you do it?
That's proven to be enough
of a defense right now.
But the very prospect
of it is still there.
AUDIENCE: If they
did that, though, I
mean it would be obvious.
People would see it
happening, right?
So would--
PAUL VIGNA: I think, too, the
whole thing is-- you know,
it's something that Nakamoto
addressed in the white paper.
I mean, this was something-- he
was the first one to bring this
up, this idea of a 51% attack.
And he ultimately rejected it.
Because it is ultimately
self-defeating, you're right.
People would see it.
They would understand it.
And to the extent that somebody
did take over the blockchain,
they would drive everybody else
out that then becomes useless,
becomes valueless.
And everything that they
invested, building up
to 51% or more, becomes
completely-- they
lose all their money on it.
It's an issue, but I don't--
firstly, I agree with Nakamoto.
I don't think it's going
to be a death knell
problem for Bitcoin.
When I don't think
it's going to happen,
because ultimately
it is self-defeating.
AUDIENCE: That wasn't
actually what I meant.
I meant the
individual miners who
are contributing to
the pool would notice,
and then they would stop.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MICHAEL CASEY: But it's
the same point, right?
Ultimately that you would
stop doing something
that would destroy your
value, would leave the pool
and diminish its power, and
therefore would no longer be
able to do so.
I don't know the degree
to which you even know.
I mean, that there's fraudulent
transactions that are building.
There's double spins that don't
necessarily get picked up.
I mean, I don't know enough
about the technicalities of it.
It's quite-- I would imagine
it's actually possible,
for quite some time.
There's been quite
a bit of research
into whether 51%
attacks are possible
and how it might
manifest itself.
But it might go
on for some time.
And all you're doing
is you're eroding
the value of the--
people, unaware of it,
are actually off what they
think is a legitimate chain,
and in the process, they're
just actually undermining
the reality and the
effectiveness of the system.
Now, I don't know.
Maybe somebody gets swindled.
They raise their hand.
The word gets out.
Who knows?
It could very well come out.
But that would be the
defense mechanism-- I
think you're absolutely right.
The idea that you would
expect pool members to leave,
diminish the power,
and that would
become the self-regulating
system within that.
The great concern
for me though, just
from this whole
practical perspective,
is how does this become used
from a commercial perspective
and whether companies
get involved.
If I'm a lawyer at a
Fortune 500 company,
and I wanted to maybe
think I should start
using Bitcoin for my
international procurement
or something else, and I'm a
lawyer, it's like, no, look.
I don't care.
Whether or not this
is possible or not,
this is big enough of a risk
that our-- whatever settlement
that we think we've done
could be reversed however
many months from now.
It's just not worth it.
Right?
So lawyers are
incredibly cautious.
And the very presence
of a 51% attack I think
is a challenge for
that very reason.
AUDIENCE: So I think some
of the early adopters
got into Bitcoin principally
because it's a better gold
to store a value.
I think one of the questions
as to Bitcoin's survivability
is what is it going to take
to the rest of the population
to sort of appreciate
that use case?
Do you have any
thoughts on that?
PAUL VIGNA: It's
a good question.
I mean, because I
don't know that there's
a good answer for it.
That's why it's a good question.
I mean, it's a problem,
this idea of Bitcoin
becoming a mainstream
product, it's a problem.
However, the solution,
I think, is just time.
This is something that is going
to have to prove itself out
over a period of
years before people
become comfortable enough that
they don't think about it.
You know, it's funny.
I was thinking about this on
the plane when I was coming over
here yesterday.
Because I came over
on a plane, right?
So I flew from New York in
about five or six hours--
MICHAEL CASEY: [INAUDIBLE].
PAUL VIGNA: No.
But, I mean, think about it.
I got on a plane.
I got on a giant
hulking piece of metal
that went up 30,000 feet in
the air and in five hours
transported me 3,000 miles.
If anything goes wrong on
that plane, I am a dead man.
Dead.
30,000 feet?
Forget it.
It's gone.
I got on a plane without
even thinking about it.
I was excited.
I was happy.
I thought, oh, great,
I'm going to fall asleep
in San Francisco.
That's a great thing.
Because the technology
has proven itself out
over the course of a century.
People don't even think
about getting on planes.
about getting in a car
and driving on a highway
at 80 miles an hour.
Because the technology
has proven itself out
over a long, long
period of time.
Bitcoin is going to have to
go through that same proving
period before the
mainstream people use it
without even thinking about
it or worrying about it.
Oh, it's digital money.
Bitcoin, I'll pick one, boom.
It's going to take time
for it to prove itself out.
And if it can't
prove itself out,
well, then it's just
going to die away.
And it'll be another idea
that was neat and interesting,
and got some adherence,
and didn't make it.
MICHAEL CASEY: I'll
just have one last word
that I think might
round this thing out.
And that is that I think
absolutely we've kind
of reached our plateau, our
limit for how many mainstream
folks are going to
go and say, hey, this
would be a great tool
for me to go on and buy
my groceries with.
And for all the reasons we cite,
it's just not a very attractive
currency to be used.
The big question,
then, is moving it
to the next phase is how it
becomes adopted by companies--
how it's adopted by corporates,
institutions, organizations.
That's going to
be the next phase.
And we're probably going to
have to go through that phase
before we bring all of the
general public on board.
That's why this question
that we're talking about here
is important, because
these guys have
got a different set
of motives from what
the early adopters had.
And that's why the
debate is critical.
But I don't think we're going
to-- the idea, the dream
that we would just sort of
automatically move gradually
through the population, and we'd
all sort of start picking up
this thing and using
it to pay for our gas
or whatever, it
was a pipe dream.
And therefore, the next phase
is this corporate phase.
And how it plays
out is critical.
So just a way to round it out.
MALE SPEAKER: And on
that note, please join me
in thanking Michael and Paul.
[APPLAUSE]